hey I'm Olivia mine and this is my very
boring intro hi I'm kinky Mike okay
we're here for the wired autocomplete
interview so we pull this off and then
it tells us what they're searching like
who's giggling okay we'll find out right
now watch this we'll see what this one
is
Hey keegan-michael key do you think can
I do that I just pull this off right now
watch this Oh
nationality is keegan-michael key all
right I'm Filipino
Phillipa what a mullet I've gotten
Guatemalan in the past that's Hispanic
they went as a matter of fact answer the
second question first I am a bi-racial I
am half african-american and half white
now because I just recently did my
23andme let me just get in-depth for a
sec yeah what they tell ya he just said
guys it's really easy you just pay $100
and then spit at somebody that one
serial killer he kinda got they were
able to track him down because a
relative of his did like one of those
ancestry yeah exactly so like if you are
a serial killer don't do don't do it
you're gonna have to just you know never
know what you are beause you know what
you are so you have to live with that
you live with your mother with it then
okay but what are you oh I'm sorry guys
so I'm 50% 51 to 50% West African but it
doesn't give me the country it just West
African and then I'm 50% and it's up for
some reason like 49.9% Western European
most of it Belgium so that is yes so I
love waffles and Travis Dales this guy
who is KITT Michael Caine is a
Guatemalan actor from hey I'm just a guy
I'm just a middle-class guy from Detroit
parents were social workers ran a drug
cartel for a while just a gun did you
find a camera asking you to love him
like all actors to please love me here
we go you ready let's go looks like if
key michael keys what am i doing right
now right now I'm doing the wired
autocomplete Enter
that's what guess what probably not the
first person who's answered that
question that way
survey says you ready for this one bit
blank keegan-michael key
why hit why him that such a mean dude
why help you because I exist I deserve
to be loved and adored I know Keegan is
about your movie why him the unit isn't
good the film white hair
yeah I was by the way you were he's
looking you non-aggressive me where they
liked it that's why they're all I was in
that film he wasn't he great
you were honestly the best part of that
movie I mean it was a great movie I
really loved you in it every day more
Keegan in it Oh God Olivia Munn what do
you think this gosh
Olivia Munn heritage brother oh that's
exciting my brother mm-hmm I have two
brothers my older brother James owns his
own motorcycle company he has a custom
motorcycle company and my younger
brother is getting his PhD in physics at
the University of Virginia right now and
I am the disappointment in the family
and I under its world-famous actor is
the leader my mom is so excited she kept
saying like make sure to save your money
but say it like your mom and say mom
tell me other day she said mom don't
know how much money you have but I think
maybe you have enough to buy a house in
Costa Rica if anything happened you
don't want to do Hollywood anymore we
open smoothie shop and then here's what
you got this is the best part and then
we went book boards my book board what's
the book board so you know in water
should but you think reeva $25 for whole
day they don't use whole day they come
back after two hour we get to reread
okay 25 you say hey you so whole day no
one use whole day to our bring back you
reap me rent so your mom's making this a
lot of thought but also like mom we made
like 195 bucks for the day and she's
like yeah who need Hollywood it would be
amazing of this next one said Olivia
Munn book boards martial arts I have a
black belt in Taekwondo and I did grow
up doing martial arts and I talked about
it a lot because when I was doing x-men
when she were excellent in nothing I
just watch that the other night did you
mind watching it I just got like like
Fox movies something like app why am i
angry and then I started watch and then
it happened to be on apocalypse happened
to be on an air web all my buddies in
this yeah my friend this beautiful and a
laser rip
but wait a minute you wait okay um I am
a Chinese German Irish English Chen I
won Wimbledon last year Wimbledon Street
in Greenwich Connecticut okay here we go
here we go here we go watch this he can
make it like okay
he um smoke there's a smoke speak French
oh gosh when when when so I don't speak
French I speak French Canadian oh where
did my keegan-michael key go to
University he will University I went to
college at the University of Detroit
Mercy a Catholic college and then I got
my master's degree at Penn State
University we are I'm a proud Nittany
Lion and a proud Titan so that's that's
the answer to that question can I get
into de Vries I couldn't get into the
front I know I have no practical skills
keegan-michael key go grow up I grew up
in Detroit Michigan I would like to say
for everybody who's watching this from
my part of the country I am NOT from
Southfield Michigan okay I was born in
south to a bishop but I grew up and had
all of my formative years in the city of
Detroit next car yes there we go here we
go that fit done you're fine it's paper
okay Olivia Munn why don't I have any
like before afters are good ready okay
look at my predator yes that's the movie
I'm in right now mm-hmm yep I'm gonna be
one truck I did a small guest star on
that movie or shadows TV show I don't
remember how me if I did one rooms that
really by America's Got Talent is the
only show i watch religiously and they
asked if I wanted to be a guest judge
and I was a hundred percent and I got
the golden buzzer and then they vote and
then whoever wins wins like a million
dollars whoa
a million dollars you know last year's
winner it was it last year the way
you're born last year's of the year for
was a little girl who did comedy with
rabbits I did see right I did see that a
million dollars I know this is not what
anybody wants in this room right now she
how much money you want a dance fever in
1979 $5,000
Julianne what if you won the Grand Prix
25,000 loud what the can you talk about
a million dollars for a rabbit
it's inflation and it's talent a billion
dollars per person
wrong business I do martial arts and I
that's it here we go listen guys look
keegan-michael key yeah I'm married I'm
very married I've been amazed I've been
married yes I've been married 11 weeks
as of the time of this taping so who
knows when you see this how long we'll
have been married I'm still I'm a very
bubbly happy newlywed wouldn't you say
yes well I love her I love them together
yes Oh Michael key mmm related to do we
I am a spirit I am spirit of the rock
what would you be the pebble ha ha ha
I'm not I am NOT a physically related to
him we were both we both belong to a
group called the caramel Patrol but
that's for real yeah where's the caramel
Patrol anybody who's like our complexion
do you guys like a neighborhood oh yeah
yeah yeah we were hired by crafts by
Kraft Foods and we look for those nice
little square caramels at least that's a
filling and then Dwayne's like yeah
we're solid is very tall I am 6 feet and
3/4 of an inch
I try to be an honest person we usually
just go 6 1 like football players and
they lie about their height they 3/4 of
an inch but what I'm doing Alexander
Technique I'm 6 1 and 1/4 looking little
kid blip you just turn the camera over
there my publicist but there I did I
just say it's my wait I knew that was
good no you okay sweetheart
Olivia Munn haircut do you know my hair
we measured it cause I to measure it for
x-men my hair we measured goes one inch
a month one inch a month inch a month
that's it what do you that's that is
like no it's just no Olivia Munn Olivia
Munn pair parents parents I guessed it
yeah she hasn't I have him channels I'm
sure Olivia mine x-men yes I was in
x-men apocalypse
this has been your very heavily edited
wired auto-complete interview good night
and have a pleasant tomorrow
good night